cards will go through a lot of
iterations right and numbers change
all the time sometimes they change in
the middle of
games right i've literally had play test
games where like i cast a spell
we talk about it for a minute decide
this is crazy change one of the numbers
as the spell is resolving things happen
quick here you gotta keep up
hi i'm matt tabak i'm an editor and game
designer with wizards of the coast
and this is magic the gathering support
joseph bell cc you have tweeted to me
i have a legitimate question and again
this is good you should always
be upfront that your question is
legitimate so i take it seriously
why does everyone hate mono white so
much
in magic the gathering i yearn to know
the answer
or is this just some in-joke that i'm
too stupid to get
i don't think everyone hates mono white
one of the cool things about magic is
there are a lot of strategies right
there are a lot of things you can do
some are very aggressive creature based
rush decks
you have combo decks that kind of aim to
finish off your opponent in one turn you
have ones that are based on
casting instances and sorceries ones
that are creature based
ones that feature lots of planeswalkers
ones that feature no planeswalkers
there's
a million strategies out there and
everyone has their favorites and their
least favorites especially if you run
into a kind of deck that you lose to all
the time that can easily become your
least favorite cool thing that magic
lets you do
is kind of change your strategy right
a good way to get better is to pay
attention to what you're losing to
and i know most of the time it's just
stupid luck and i hate everything but if
you move past that
and look at what actually your opponent
did or what you didn't do
during a game this is the key to getting
better recognizing
that a wide variety of strategies are
viable a wide variety of counter
strategies are viable
and that's how you become a more
successful magic player is this some in
joke i don't think it's an in joke i
think
it's popular to hate on successful
strategies and mono white has
historically been a successful strategy
it's had its ups and downs like
everything
are you too stupid to get it i haven't
met you i don't know it's possible i
don't think it is
and the fact that you play magic is a
pretty strong indicator that you're not
too stupid so i think you're doing okay
joseph and uh thank you for your
question all right shep
in training asks random magic the
gathering question
if you attack with a two-two creature
and are blocked by a two-two creature
which creature or creatures are
destroyed let's talk about combat okay
this is kind of the essence of the game
right creatures
battling each other every creature has
two important stats when it comes to
combat
the first number to the left of the
slash is its power
and that tells you how much damage the
creature deals and the second number
after the slash that's its toughness it
tells you if a creature
is dealt that much damage in one turn
it's destroyed so when creatures fight
or when creatures battle
in combat what's gonna happen is each
creature is gonna deal damage equal to
its power
to the other one and that's gonna happen
at the same time so in your example you
got two two twos
battling it out let's call them a and b
just to creatively name the creatures
creature a
is gonna deal two damage because its
power is two to creature b
creature b is gonna deal two damage
because that's its power
to creature a both of them take two
damage to be destroyed that's their
toughness
so in your example both creatures are
destroyed all right let's
check out our next question from friar
tug of resist to the idiocracy
add wizard's magic question opponent
casts act of treason
in response i cast heroic intervention
in response op
cass lightning bolt stack resolves three
damage to creature with three toughness
creature gains indestructible and hex
proof active trees and fizzles
does the creature die friar tug first of
all thank you for sending your question
in the form of a haiku
that makes it just more entertaining for
me unfortunately i
don't think i can answer in the form of
a haiku
um i will however answer this question
involving the stack and how things
resolve
using interpretive dance
act of choosing heroic intervention
lightning so what happens is things are
going to resolve
top to bottom the last speller ability
cast
is going to resolve first so lightning
bolt is going to resolve first it's
going to deal three damage
to a creature with three toughness now
right away that creature is going to be
destroyed this is going to happen before
heroic intervention
resolves so there are rules in the game
called state-based actions and what
these do they're kind of like the
janitors of magic right they come
through and they clean up
any situation that needs cleaning up so
after any speller ability resolves
the game is checked to see is there a
creature with lethal damage still on the
battlefield is there a creature with
zero toughness hanging out on the
battlefield
and if so it's going to clean it up and
get it off the
off the battlefield so after lightning
bolt resolves
the creature is destroyed before the
other two spells
get a chance to resolve so heroic
intervention will still resolve and give
permanence you control indestructible
and hex proof
but the creature that was destroyed by
the lightning bolt is no longer there
the act of treason will also not resolve
because its target
is now sitting in the graveyard and i
hope what i have done
here friar tag
clears things up for you okay let's
check out another question this time
from at the serif men
question for mtg twitter that's me uh
does anyone remember
any other specific card nicknames the
ones i got
are bob gary skittles and mom
but i know there's more i'm forgetting
there are in fact a lot more that you
may be forgetting
of course bob is dark confidant it was
given that nickname because the art
the original art of dark confidant was
an image of
bob marr pro player that won the magic
invitational which was an event
the prize for that was to get his
likeness on a magic card gary of course
is the
gray merchant of ashvidel skittles is
skitherex the blight dragon
and mom is mother of runes so these are
you know nicknames for cards that have
developed over the years
probably the most popular nickname of
all time for a magic card is
tim for prodigal sorcerer this is of
course a creature that tapped to deal
damage
uh given the nickname tim based on its
kind of likeness to a
wizard and monty python so they call me
tim
this spawned of course tim on a stick
tim on a boat basically anything that
tapped to deal one damage got a tim
related nickname some older cards have
nicknames uh hypnotic specter is hippie
there were the pump knights two white
two black knights order of leitbor
and a couple others that had abilities
where you could pump
mana into them to increase their power
so those were collectively called the
pump nights
uh they're a lot yeah do some google
searching there there are
quite a few out there some not super
appropriate for this
video and we're just gonna end uh this
question on that one
all right christian calligraphy corner
asks to all magic the gathering plays
i'm a play let's see what the question
is question of the day
are there any mono red creature cards
that work only if you have a
snow-covered mountain
comment below now some of you may be
watching this video and you're looking
to get into magic and you don't know all
the terms yet so you're like what are
what is mana what is lands
what's he talking about so mana is
basically the system of energy that we
use
in the game so it's kind of a resource
system a game of magic is all about is
you know wizards casting spells and to
cast those spells you need to
have enough energy to do it and that's
called mana the very easiest way to get
mana is through your lands
each turn you play one land from your
hand onto the battlefield and it's kind
of a land you have that you control it
and you can tap that land which means
you know turn it
kind of indicate that it's used for the
turn and that gives you
the energy that you need the mana you
need to be able to do other things in
the game like
summon creatures cast spells activate
abilities kind of
do things to interact with your opponent
and further your goal
of beating that opponent my search
didn't turn up any cards that
any red creature cards that work only if
you have a snow-covered mountain there
are gonna be a lot of creatures out
there that get
better if you have a snow-covered
mountain so for example oron yeti that
can give your creatures first strike so
look for cards that require snow mana of
some kind
or ones that care about having snow
lands on the battlefield so none that
you need but there are definitely some
ones out there that get better
and our next question is from yuli
bambooli blazing archon is our card of
the day because i have a legality
question
all right i mean creatures can't attack
you check
so does that mean me as a planeswalker
directly or in general they cannot not
attack
unless targeting a specific creature all
right bamboo liuli
um let's get a couple things straight
just to make sure we're all on the same
page here
while creatively and in some of our
marketing we kind of sell that you
the player are a planeswalker that's
that's a thing in the game
it's important to note that you are a
player and planeswalkers the cards
are the only things that are
planeswalkers so when you attack
you don't attack creatures directly when
i'm saying i control a creature and i'm
going to attack you
what i'm doing is i'm basically just
sending the creature
in your direction i'm saying it's either
going to attack you
or it's going to attack a planeswalker
you control i can't attack your
creatures directly
what you can do as the defender is
decide how your creatures are going to
block my creature
or if they're going to block it so as
the defender you kind of have
active control over how combat is gonna
go you're gonna decide whether my
attacking creature gets blocked or not
and if it is blocked by which creature
so i can't attack your creatures
directly so if an effect says i can't
attack you
that means exactly that it can't attack
you it can still attack a planeswalker
you control
unless the effect says will specifically
say if you can't
but blazing archon doesn't say that
because blazing archon is from a time
before planeswalkers
so it just can't attack you
your planeswalkers are fair game your
creatures can never be attacked blazing
r conor no
i hope this helps all right we have a
question from elder cleric
who says at wizards magic i have a judge
question
if you attack with a colonnade or a
nissa land mobilize district
can i tap it for mana during combat and
keep it in combat
okay so what elder cleric is asking
about is cards like
celestial colonnade mobilized district
and then the character nissa
one of her kind of in her power suite is
she turns lands
into creatures so we're talking about
cards that turn lands
into creatures which presumably you then
smash face with
so the basic rule is this there's a rule
called summoning sickness which says
a creature cannot attack or tap
for any of its abilities that use the
tap symbol unless you've controlled it
from the beginning of your most recent
term so the question is if i have a land
and i turn it into a creature
can it then attack a lot of these turn
the land into a creature with haste
so you get to ignore summoning sickness
completely haste is an ability that says
as soon as i hit the battlefield on my
turn i can attack
i can use my tap abilities no problem if
the land entered the battlefield under
your control
that turn and you then turn it into a
creature
it hasn't been under your control since
the beginning of the turn
so in that case once it becomes a
creature it can't attack that turn
and it can't be tapped for mana that
turn unless again
it has haste if you turn a land that
you've controlled for the entire turn
you turn it into a creature
that new creature can attack because the
rule doesn't care whether it's been a
creature or not it only cares how long
you've controlled that permanent
so as long as you controlled it from the
beginning of your turn until now
it can attack and it can tap for mana if
it's a creature
now can you keep it in combat if the
land
attacks most of the time it's going to
become tapped
so you can't also tap it for mana but
if the land has vigilance which is an
ability that lets you attack without
becoming tapped
you'll be an attacking creature that's
untapped and then you can tap for mana
so yes you can do both
if you have vigilance hope this helps
let's go to our next question from at
thiefs underscore magic
a question for at wizards underscore
magic wait are we related
we like cousins or something that's wild
that's our last name
how does changeling tribal work with
code of arms help me out here
all right all right thief's magic a
great question coat of arms
uh historically a very popular card but
sometimes misunderstood
what coat of arm says is that each
creature on the battlefield
gets plus one plus one for each other
creature that shares a creature type
with it now coat of arms doesn't really
care
how many creature types you share with
another creature
so if you have two goblins on the
battlefield they'll see each other and
say hey
i'm a goblin you're a goblin let's each
get plus one plus one
if i have a changeling on the
battlefield now changeling is an ability
that says a creature is every creature
type so it's a goblin it's an elf it's a
dragon it's a wizard
it's a coward it's a drag it's like 180
of these things
it's everything if it sees a goblin on
the battlefield
it says i'm a goblin you're a goblin
let's each get plus one plus one
if there's two changelings on the
battlefield they say
i'm everything you're also everything
they each
oh still only get plus one plus one
because it's the number of creatures
that share a creature type not the
number of creature types
moving on to our next question it comes
in from at one
sacred serif i have a magic the
gathering question
if a person has a hand with no lands and
no cards that can be played can they
burn their hand
at wizards underscore magic couple
things i want to talk about here with
this question so the first is
mulligans at the beginning of the game
you draw seven cards
now for any reason if you don't like
those seven cards
if you have too many lands if you have
not enough lands
if you've built your deck around a
particular strategy and your important
cards aren't there
whatever if you don't like what you see
you can shuffle it back into your
library
draw another seven see if you like those
now when you're done
as many times as you've shuffled your
hand back in you have to take that many
cards from your hand
and put it on the bottom of your library
so if i mulligan once
i'm gonna start the game with a six card
hand that's kind of the balancing factor
i get another shot to get what i want
but i lose a card in the process
and if i mulligan again then i'm gonna
draw seven
and say okay these seven i like i need
to take two cards
and put them on the bottom of your
library so however many times you
shuffle back in that's how many cards
you're gonna lose before you actually
start the game
so that's a mulligan system that lets
you sort of
have a little bit more control over your
opening hands make sure you get
something you're happy with so the game
plays out well for you what you might be
talking about in your question
is there used to be still is probably in
some cases
a house rule that said if at any point
during the game if my hand
has no lands or nothing i can play i can
then like
either shuffle it in and draw more cards
i can put it in the graveyard
and draw more cards i can do something
like that and those are not
official rules that is a house rule
thing that some groups
embraced but according to the official
rules of magic
once the game starts you're in you can't
just get rid of your hand and draw more
cards
because you don't like what you have in
hand and we have a question here from at
slumber underscore spirit what is the
weirdest most obscure interesting mtg
rules interaction you know
it's not the most complex thing in the
world but it's just cute
the the card i will point to is a card
called
faith's fetters it's an aura and it has
enchant permanent
which means it can be attached to any
permanent now generally you put this on
creatures because what the aura does is
it stops them from attacking or blocking
it also stops their abilities generally
this is a defensive aura that you're
gonna put on things threatening you so
what you do is you get two of them
and you put them on whatever it doesn't
matter what they're on to begin with the
important thing is
is faith setters says enchant permanent
which means
you can use a card to move that aura
onto a different permanent so let's say
i have faith fetters one face fighters
two
doesn't matter what they're on i'm gonna
move faiths
fetters one and that's a hard card to
say so the fact that i picked this tells
you how much i love this interaction
and i'm gonna change it i'm gonna move
it so it is enchanting
faith's fetters number two so now i have
faith betters one
enchanting faith spinner's two
enchanting something else
doesn't matter find a spell find a card
that can move an aura i'm gonna cast
another one
and this time i'm gonna move faiths
fetters two
so it is enchanting faithsfetters1 so
now i have face fetters one enchanting
face fitters two
face fetters two enchanting face fetters
one why did i pick this card i have to
say 17 million times i don't know but i
did
so now the two auras are attached
to each other they're hugging each other
for life
they're sitting on a battlefield that is
defined
by chaos creatures are
running past them at full speed
in an effort to destroy other creatures
and deal damage to your enemy and these
two face fetters are sitting there
hugging each other
clinging to life they have no ties to
any other permanent
they have no connection to anything
happening around them
they're just relying on each other for
life
for safety for security and at the end
of the day
isn't that what we're all doing just
clinging to safety and security and life
finding another person or thing
or people i don't judge whatever
but holding on to them isn't that what
it's all about
right there in your game of magic while
you're throwing lightning bolts at your
opponent's head
and destroying all their creatures and
stone raining their lands because you're
some kind of jerk
but here are those faith sweaters
holding on to each other
it's beautiful it is a beautiful rules
interaction
i'm sorry what was your question let me
look at it again
and we're done thank you so much for
your questions i had a blast i hope you
did too
this has been magic the gathering
support